chris franzola does it get any better
than this guy
you'll see what i mean hello
i hope everyone's having a nice covered
19 uh vacation right now like i
what i decided to do uh with this time
that we all have off
is i decided to go back and stay with my
elderly parents for two weeks back on
long island where i'm from
i stayed with mom and dad for two weeks
just me mom and dad back in the house i
grew up in
in the bedroom i grew up in just me mom
and dad uh i don't know if you know this
about my mom and dad they get up real
early they are
up they're up at 4am talking really loud
in the kitchen
about how they're gonna prepare their
bread that day that's a big day for mom
and dad will they toast it
maybe they'll toast it maybe they won't
toast it maybe they'll have a bagel
today maybe english muffin are you guys
bored by this
you could i had to deal with it for two
weeks you could deal with her 10 more
seconds okay
so then uh mom and dad if you know they
buy everything in bulk
uh only two of them in the house but
they buy everything at costco
and they go to costco every day they
love they and they wear the youth the
costco uniform
in to the costco they are head to toe
kirkland
upon entering costco and then they buy
more
my father is the mayor of kirkland they
love it they buy a ton
i had to choke down 75 bagels when i was
there otherwise it wasn't fiscally
responsible what they've done
their entire life has been turned upside
down because i don't know if you guys
are familiar
they don't do the samples at costco
anymore because of the covet 19
situation my parents were living on a
steady diet
i believe for the last seven eight years
of uh costco samples so now they're
just their life has been turned up so if
you ever want to truly emasculate
yourself you're thinking
how do you do i recommend uh just
driving around in the back seat of your
parents car
uh that's kind of fun just getting in
the back seat they hold up the seat feel
like a child
you get in the back seat and then they
uh crank up an
am radio yeah they still have that am
about as loud as it goes
and then and then my mom and dad just
yell out climates of cities they're
never going to go to
i've never been to like it's uh 43
degrees in omaha today
and that's the driver with mom and dad i
don't know if you ever watched the 280
year old people getting out of a car
that's kind of fun takes about 45 50
minutes
bones cracking and popping the whole
time and they get everywhere er
i staying with your elderly parents you
realize
i thought i'd go the rest of my life not
knowing who had a better scrapbooking
section
michael's art supply a hobby lobby turns
out everybody
it's michael's art supply mom and i went
every day
get there early not even open yet we
wait outside
wait outside sitting in the car
listening to the am radio
and finally i asked my mom i said mom
why are we here so early it's not even
open until 9am she goes i don't think
i don't get caught up in the rush is is
there a rush
are people [ __ ] each other looking for
glitter it's a bit of a melee around
10 a.m all right fair enough i don't be
a part of that
so then mom and i go in once the doors
are open we get some scrapbooking needs
and then we sit at the kitchen table and
we'll scrapbook for hours
i never thought i'd be the type of
person sitting at a kitchen table
scrapbooking at my age but
hey you know what these are these are
strange times we're in and that's what i
wound up doing
five days into scrapbooking maybe you
people aren't scrapbookers i don't know
but i'll explain what it is you put a
fun picture in the scrapbook and then
you put fun things around that picture
to signify what's in the picture
say i was putting a picture of this
performance i put a picture of me
standing in what is my bedroom really
it's supposed to be banana mores but
it's my bedroom
i put all this together myself last
night at about 10 o'clock
and that would be me trying to assemble
this backdrop
and a picture and that would signify
this performance that would be my
scrapbooking of this
okay so i did that with mom for about
you know five days in a row before i
realized i have no more scrapbooking
ideas
so then i looked on facebook so i had a
message from a guy i went to high school
with
haven't seen him in 35 years he writes
me on facebook and he says
are you in town right now i said yes i
am he goes that's crazy
i still live in town i said yeah i kind
of saw that coming
he goes i'd love to catch up with you
hey doing pretty well they
doing pretty well i just uh bombed at
bananamores for
three minutes in my bedroom it's safe to
say things are going pretty well
anyway i meet this guy for lunch like i
said i haven't seen him in 35 years his
name is george
i take him to a tgi fridays nothing's
too good for my friends
i walk in i he smiles a big smile
his front tooth is gone the front one
the important one you know the one where
the one most prominently displayed in
his mouth the front two gone that
i don't that's not you he should we have
a three hour lunch he didn't even
mention what happened to it all i could
think about is where's your front tooth
i didn't say it of course
i'm a d i don't want to embarrass the
guy sensitive subject
i'm sure i don't want to bring it up but
i mean how's the guy gonna have corn on
the cob that's all i was thinking like
he ordered a spinach
artichoke dip as an appetizer that bad
choice
that is a very front tooth heavy dish i
didn't realize it either until i saw him
struggling with it
you know he the dip fair enough soft the
chips once he hit those oh flying
everywhere he couldn't handle that he
didn't have the tools to work with that
corn on the cob forget it comes time for
a summer barbecue at this guy's house
it's going to be a disaster
you don't think there's no whose carpet
is later that day at the picnic
when you see one cobb in the garbage can
with all the kernels missing except one
row of kernels
if you're people i don't know you guys
you have friends relatives with the
front tooth out this goes to everybody
missing their front tooth you got to get
that taken care of that affects other
people's
that affects us we can't focus when
that's out we're not saying anything
because we're decent nice people
but trust there's not another thought in
our head then why is your
front tooth out you got to get that i
know it's expensive put a chicklet or
tic tac or a piece of loose leaf paper
scotch tape
just mask it for a little while while
you take you out for chicken wings
okay so then i went back to my house mom
and i scrapbooked and
now i'm here so thank you very much
happy
quarantine
now with bananas i want more thanks for
coming to bananas
more
you